learn how to make the web a better place
for everyone in this course you'll dive
into what it truly means to build
accessible websites and why it's
important instructor and web developer
Frederick ritfolk will teach you the
fundamentals of accessible development
like understanding contrast ratios
exploring the accessibility tree getting
familiar with wcag levels and much
more Hello amazing coders and welcome to
this course on accessible development
when we are developing anything we are
creating content and we say that content
is accessible when it is available and
its functionality can be operated by
anyone therefore accessible development
means to develop with everyone in mind
including all the users who have some
sort of disability developing accessibly
isn't just the right thing to do but any
future employer will want to know that
you have all their users in mind when
making decisions and it's also the law
in some countries here's a website which
is currently suffering a lot of
accessibility issues in this course
it'll be your job to save this website
you will of course not be alone my name
is Frederick and I will be your teacher
together we will learn how to get some
easy wins to help improve accessibility
with minimal effort you will also find
that many of these techniques will help
you create interfaces that are more
pleasant and easy to use for all users
by the end of this course you will have
the skills to to help build a more
inclusive digital
world before we get coding I want to
show you some of the various types of
assistive Technologies and how our
accessibility improvements work we'll
also touch on accessibility testing
methods there are various types of
assessive technologies that benefit from
accessible web content these include but
are not limited to screen readers speech
recognition software screen magnifiers
and alternative input devices designed
for people with motor skill impairments
screen readers are one of the most
common types and they rely heavily on
headings links and form labels for
navigation at the heart of web
accessability is the accessibility tree
a key part of how browsers interact with
assisted Technologies this tree is a
simplified representation of the page
focusing on elements important for
accessibility like headings links and
form
labels this could be our code and the
browser translates that into a visual UI
but at the same time it also translates
our code into an object called the
accessibility tree which contains a lot
of important information and context in
text form the improvements we are going
to make in this course will make our
components available inside this
accessibility tree and provide assistive
Technologies with this important context
here are two buttons that look the same
in the visual UI because we style them
the same but in the accessibility tree
the button made using a div tag lacks
information and context when you use
semantic HTML that is the right element
for the right purpose the browser
automatically feeds the correct
information into the accessibility tree
this helps assistive Technologies to
navigate and interpret the content
accurately keyboard accessibility is
another Cor Corner Stone of web
accessibility and by using correct HTML
elements like button tags a tags and
form elements you sort of get keyboard
accessibility for free this means these
elements are naturally focusable and
operable with a keyboard no extra coding
required we will get some hands-on
experience with this later in the course
here is how we can access the
accessibility tree in our web app in my
example I'm using Chrome as my browser
and if we open up our developer tools
there will be a tab called accessibility
click on that and click on enable full
page accessibility tree your developer
tools will ask you to reload and when
you do that you will see an
accessibility button popping up if you
click on it you will see the
accessibility
tree this is not exclusive to Chrome
other browsers like Firefox also gives
us access to viewing the accessibility
tree I'll leave you with a link to a
complete guide on how to work with the
accessibility Tree in Chrome dep tools
so how do we test our accessibility well
the first way is quite straightforward
we can experience our own site using for
example a screen reader to understand
how our content is presented there are
tools like contrast Checkers that help
ensure our text is readable against its
background we also have automated tools
at our disposal like lighthouse in
Chrome accessibility inspector in
Firefox or a software called called axe
these softwares can help identify common
accessibility issues and we can also use
AI assistants to test our code in terms
of accessibility for example we can
supply our code to the AI and ask if it
detects any poor color contrasts or
missing labels or if we have used the
wrong native HTML element for the job I
myself use chat GPT daily for this and
much else if you are using Chrome as
your browser you can find Lighthouse by
opening up your Dev tools and going to
the lighthouse tab up here there you can
select what you want Lighthouse to do
for example to test your s's
accessibility on desktop then you just
press analyze page load when Lighthouse
is done analyzing we will get a score of
0 to 100 on how accessible our ctis not
shown here is also a detailed walk
through of any accessibility issues that
light house found so that we can
identify them and fix them it's time for
some Hands-On learning let's head into
some code and learn about accessible
color contrast see you in the next
lesson before we start we need to know
what is considered accessible there are
well-defined requirements on things like
text images the HTML code and so on
these are called the web content
accessibility guidelines these
guidelines have different levels called
a able a and AA a the a level means it's
not accessible the able a level is
considered accessible but what we really
want to achieve is the highest grade AAA
whenever possible let's look at our
first specific example color contrast
for text as in the contrast that text
has against its background black text
against the black background has a
contrast ratio value of one 1: one it's
the same color the highest contrast
ratio is black and white that has a
ratio of
1:21 this light gray text against the
bronze background has a value of a bit
over two the dark gray text against the
silver background has a value of a bit
over four and the black text against the
gold background has a value of almost 19
to demonstrate further here's a rainbow
with dark blue text inside each strip
and similar to what we just saw the
contrast values are written in each
stripe this dark blue text on this red
background has a ratio of 3.32 it's not
very good and difficult to read we can
easily check the contrast value of text
against its Background by visiting an
online contrast Checker like this one
and this is a link you can click on or
if we for example are using Chrome as
our browser we can check such a value by
pressing control shift C on PC or
command shift C on Mac and then hovering
over the text under accessibility you
will see the contrast value similar
functionality exists in other browsers
like Firefox and Edge if you using
something else than Chrome I recommend
looking up if and how your browser can
analyze color contrasts I want you to
pause here and give this a go and check
that the contrast values are indeed what
I have written here by hovering over
each and every
text great so now you might be wondering
what color contrast values are good to
be accessible normal text should at
least have the value of 4.5 and at least
three for large text but what we really
want to achieve are these AAA
requirements it's time for your first
challenge I want you to change the color
of each text so that they they all
fulfill the wca's ablea requirements
which is a contrast ratio of 4.5 pause
now and try this
out okay hopefully you gained some
insights if you tried black in white
text you probably noticed how they had
good contrast on different backgrounds
in fact you probably managed to achieve
a contrast value of over seven for most
backgrounds which is the best possible
achievement but no no matter which text
color we use white or black or anything
else the contrast values can't reach
seven for the red and green backgrounds
pause quickly here and think about how
you would solve
this so in this case you would need to
either change the background color or
make the text bigger I have a challenge
waiting for you on this but while on the
topic of colors I want to show a brief
example of another aspect to think about
when using color in an accessible manner
follow me into the next
lesson I want to give you a little heads
up on using colors in your apps because
while colors are a super way to
communicate information we should not
rely solely on color instead we should
combine color with shapes or with text
or ideally both here we have two simple
user cards quite similar to what we
often see in chat applications they have
a profile picture a name and an
indicator to communicate if the user is
online or offline indicated with either
green or red color I want you to have a
think about how you could improve this
indicator using shape and text pause
here did you cheat and looked up a chat
app you use to see how they do it if so
perfect that's exactly what I would have
done a simple way to make this more
accessible is to pair the color
indicator with an icon as well as to add
the status text so that it looks
something like this there might
sometimes be cultural differences as
well in how colors are interpreted but
with these changes alone the over 300
million people with some degree of color
blindness in the world will thank you
for this consideration now it's time to
test our knowledge of accessible color
contrasts now let's apply what we just
learned on this website's
homepage the website belongs to a
company that delivers groceries to your
window by drones quite futuristic
sounding but perhaps how we will get our
onions and soy sauce one day soon but as
you can probably already tell some big
mistakes with color contrast are
currently being made here's your
challenge
identify any parts of the page where the
text contrast is poor and then change
those parts so that they fulfill the AAA
requirements and just so you remember
you have your AAA requirements right
here there are actually multiple ways to
solve this accessibility issue I leave
it to you to choose how to do it pause
now and give this a sh
I am really curious to know how you went
about making these text contrast
improvements the first part of the
challenge was to identify any parts of
the page where the text contrast isn't
good enough this is obviously the case
here with the word eats which is green
and it sort of Blends into the
background of of the Green in the image
behind it and it doesn't really solve
anything to change the color of this
word to uh black color uh because the
contrast will will still be poor on top
of the image and if we change it to
White well it will be uh impossible to
see outside the image one way you might
have gone about solving this challenge
is to find the the selector for that
specific word which
is right here and then added
display block and look at that what that
does is it forces the word to be on its
own separate line it takes up the
maximum width and that solves our text
contrast issue another way to solve this
and perhaps my own preferred way is to
instead
of making the title of our homepage two
lines I would simply focus on the hero
image and maybe make that a little bit
smaller something like that and that
does it although it looks a little bit
awkward so I'm going to push it down a
little bit from the
top something like that that's one part
the other part of the page you probably
immediately recognized as having poor
text contrast is the footer dark green
on dark gray is going to be hard for
just about anyone to
read so we go down to the footer in our
CSS and this is where our icons and text
get their color and if we change this to
white or FFF
FFF that looks so much better so much
much easier to read and I think we are
ready for a new section on our homepage
now we have an about section where we
are told the background story of the
company and how the higher of AI and
Robotics Ariana Grande founded the
company but once again there's a huge
issue in seeing what the text actually
reads so one more time we need to make
the text much much more readable by
improving the text contrast this is a
bit tricky because it's a background
image but tricky is the word and we have
a trick up Our Sleeve I want to
introduce to you a CSS property that you
may or may not be familiar with here's
your challenge I want you to practice
your Google Fu and search for background
blend mode it's a CSS property and see
if you can figure out how to make make
the background image in our about
section brighter so that the text is
much more readable pause here and give
this your best
chot if you figured out how that is
amazing now let's do it
together we go up
to where we find the background image
being
stated and we are going to add two CSS
properties round
color I'm going to make this white and
then a stands for Alpha and here you can
set a value of 0 to 1 and we're going to
do a high number
0.85 so far nothing has changed now we
use
background blend mode and we write
lighten and did you see that all of a
sudden it got lighter so it Blends the
background color with the background
image cool right maybe this seems
limiting at first maybe you love the
colors pink and white and wanted to
build a website with those colors and
then I come along and ask you to rethink
that well Einstein famously talked about
how how he limited his wardrobe to just
a few select options so that he wouldn't
get overwhelmed by all the options which
he called option paralysis so much like
Einstein may have omitted pink and white
outfits in his wardrobe we can omit pink
text on white background or vice versa
in web development next up we will move
on to making images accessible to
everyone see you there
when we add images to a web page we
should consider the fact that some users
cannot see images they need a text
alternative and as we will see this text
is simply added inside the images HTML
tags as attributes the text given here
is not visually displayed on the page
but is hidden in the code to be accessed
by screen readers and search engines
like Google so what is best practice
when writing alternative text for
images this first example is way too
wordy we want to be as concise as
possible we also shouldn't start by
writing an image off because the screen
reader will say it's an image
anyway the second example here is great
but you may wonder do we have to add
alternative text to all images well yes
and no we need to add the alt tag to all
the images in our HTML but if an image
is purely decorative we don't need to
write any descriptive text the reason we
do this is because without it a screen
reader May read out the image file name
instead and that can be quite
annoying alternative texts mainly help
people with little or no vision people
who have turned off images to save data
and it also helps search engines like
Google to find appropriate content to
practice this we have a website
displaying a collection of strange
digital art which currently isn't very
accessible
okay time for a
challenge I want you to add appropriate
alternative text to all the images on
this web
page have a look at the Batman duck
example the uh second one when trying to
write descriptive text the text needs to
be concise but still communicate the
important parts of what the image shows
so
pause here and give this a
try okay I hope you had a good time
trying to uh describe these very strange
images we have on our page I know I had
so let me show you what I came up
with I will look at the first image here
the astronaut and then go to our HTML
and here we find it what I'm going to do
is add the alt
attribute and I came up with the text an
astronaut suspended in midair by a dark
cloud over a field of purple
grass I'm not sure that's an astronaut
but it looks like it to
me and for the second
image down here
I came up with a chair with a small
Cloud hovering over it in the desert
next to a dark
Rock and
finally this image
here I
wrote dark cubes and cylinders floating
in the air along with two glowing
orbs but if you noticed we skipped an
image
this right here is an image as
well and we find that up here in the
hero
section so this was also a challenge to
try to describe it's very
strange my best take on it was a hand
made of metallic liquid dripping
upwards again you might have described
these very differently but the important
part is that you got practice in
applying an ALT tag in your HTML to
every image and writing a concise or as
concise description as possible and
finally one thing I tend to do when
writing alternative text is to end with
a period as you can see this is not
something you need to do but it makes a
screen reader do a brief pause which can
be helpful when listening to it describe
all the content on a page I have one
last question for you which is what if
this hero section had a background image
like this one should we add an
alternative text to this image the
answer is no not all images should have
an alternative text if the image for
example has a label or an adherent text
that describes the image an alternative
text becomes redundant we also shouldn't
give decorative images like this one an
alternative text decorative images don't
add informational content but are purely
for Aesthetics examples include
stylistic flourishes background images
or images used for spacing for such
images it's best practice to use an
empty alt
attribute like we see here having an
empty alt attribute tells the screen
readers to skip the image in the absence
of an old attribute some screen readers
May default to reading out the file name
of the image in our case here the screen
reader might read out
background.jpg this can be confusing for
users who rely on screen readers as file
names often don't provide meaningful
information about the image this is just
one example but another very common type
of decorative image that should have an
empty alt attribute are icons combined
with text think for example of the magn
glass in a search field finally we
should understand that alternative text
is important for everyone not just those
using assestive Technologies firstly
alternative text enhances the user
experience in situations where images
don't load due to slow internet or other
technical issues so let's break our own
image this is how it will look like if
our image here fails to load for
whatever reason luckily we have an
alternative text that describes the
content so that we don't miss out on any
information the image conveys if we
remove it we are left with merely a
broken image link before moving on from
this website we will also look at how we
can make the links in here more
accessible see you in the next
lesson labels for control elements like
links and buttons are very useful to all
users but getting them right is
particularly important to users with
disabilities for links you should use
the a tag in your
HTML and your links should be
recognizable as links and easy to find
and finally they should have
nonambiguous
textt what I mean by that is that anyone
should be able to understand understand
where the link will take them even out
of context the links are in so don't
just use click here or more for your
labels as screen reader users sometimes
navigate through links without reading
the context let's look at a few examples
the first link is not very accessible
why because color alone is not
sufficient to indicate the presence of a
link underlines are a popular commonly
understood way to communicate the
presence of Link
content however the text here is still
ambiguous uh we don't understand it
outside of its context so this is much
better we can clearly see it's a link
and we understand where the link will
take us even out of context now I have a
challenge for you I want you to update
all the links in the website so that
they meet the following requirements one
they can be identified as links by more
than just color alone and secondly the
link text is not ambiguous as in we
understand where the link will take us
even out of context pause here give this
your breath shot and afterwards I will
show you how I would do
it okay I hope that went
well so we have a link in each paragraph
here's
one here's
one and here is
one so we have three links to identify
and the eight tags are currently only
wrapping the he word what I would do is
to make sure that the a tag is wrapping
this whole last sentence
actually like
that now this whole sentence is a link
that can be understood outside of
context next up I'm going to apply the
same principle to the second paragraph
and make the whole last sent sentence a
link and for the third
link we do the very same
thing we transform the full sentences
into links but it's still only
communicated by color so we have to go
into our CSS and there are actually
multiple ways of making the links more
accessible one could be to make the text
more bold than the text around it but in
another way as we saw in our example
here giving it an underline is a
commonly understood uh way to
communicate that something is a
link
so if we change text decoration none to
underline we Achi an appearance that
definitely to me looks like a clickable
link in fact text decoration underline
is the default for a elements so we
could actually just remove this and the
default styling is still there let's
have a quick look at some less
traditional links let me show you an
example here I've turned our section
into a card and now the whole card is
link to more work from the artist when
making an advanced link like this we
need to do a bit more to make sure the
link is accessible because quite often
accessibility issues arise from how
they're built commonly using the a tag
to wrap the whole component like we have
done
here this is totally understandable as
an approach because it succeeds in
making the whole thing clickable but it
negatively affects the screen reading
your experience if we move to the card
using a screen reader a very long string
of text content will be read out and
only after this and I told the card is
linked which is a bit slow and maybe a
bit confusing plus elements like images
included in the card might not be
specifically announced as image either
any nested structure is lost within the
link instead the link should be
positioned inside the card without
wrapping any text now I'll will show you
how to do this
we just improved accessibility greatly
and by cheating using either CSS or
JavaScript we can make the whole card
clickable just like it was before feel
free to pause and check out my CSS
solution which you uses absolute
positioning and a pseudo selector the
CSS is a bit Advanced and out of scope
for this lesson but as you develop your
skills it's important for you to know
what the correct approach is it could
also be a good idea to add a hover
effect to the whole card like we did
here to make sure the cursor is a
pointer and also to modify the call to
action text so that the user understands
that the whole card is now clickable the
card should also be focusable if we tab
through the page since I mentioned
modifying the call to action text we
should also make that
update this is much better communication
additionally I added something called an
ARA label and I added it to the link
inside the card this will be read out by
screen reader and it's an accessible
feature to use when the link lacks a
descriptive text as in our example here
we will cover area labels in their own
scrim later on in the course at this
point you have already learned some of
the most important ways to make a
website accessible in the next lesson we
are going to return to our Skynet eats
website and apply our new skills see you
there we are back with our drone food
delivery app and we have introduced a
news section with some general info and
statistics about the company but the
website lacks alternative text for its
images and some of its links are not
accessible enough this is where you will
swoop in to save the day your task is
simple update our images so that they
have appropriate alternative texts and
update any links that are either not
recognizable as links or they have
ambiguous texts this requires you to
have a look around
and work both in our HTML and CSS pause
here and give this Your Best
Shot okay I hope that went well if you
were still unsure about anything I will
now show you exactly how I would do this
let's start with updating our images
with alternative
text the first image is this
one here we find the hero image which is
where I will add the alt tag and the
text that I chose to write reads food
delivery Dron saying I come with peace
and remember when text is part of an
image a screen reader won't be able to
read it therefore if it conveys
important information which I think in
this case it does because it
communicates humor we should add it to
our alternative text that's image one
for our new section we have this image
here of a
drone we find it right here I'll add the
all tag and I decided to Simply and
concisely call this a flying Skynet
drone maybe you just wrote a flying
drone and that's okay my thought was
that this might be skynet's own unique
design of a drone that this is an image
of and therefore it makes sense to be
specific did you notice that I left out
one thing I didn't add any period to the
end of the sentence which I am a fan of
so I'm going to do that here and also up
here I'm adding a period by the end to
give the screen reader some pause when
reading the alternative text amazing now
to the second part of the challenge
which involved our links
this link here isn't very accessible so
first I'm going to take this a tag and
wrap it
around that's better we still haven't
done anything to the CSS and we will get
there but first this is another link and
while it does a pretty good job
communicating that it's a clickable link
the text is still ambiguous so let's
change that
we go down here and then here we have to
change it to something else it will take
us to their about page so how about we
just write about
Skynet I think that makes a lot of sense
now we head to into our
CSS to update this link right here I
want it to be underlined so I'm going to
go up to the info section and this
selects the link giving it a green color
let's do text decoration
underline and there we have it
immediately recognizable as a link but
there's one more thing we can do
remember everything we learned about
text contrast well these small headlines
drones customers and Cat conflicts their
text contrast is not great we would love
them to have a contrast value of seven
or above so let's see if we can identify
these selectors in the
HTML we see that they have the class
stat heading which is right here in our
CSS and this is the color if we change
that to a lighter
gray then immediately it became much
more readable and the contrast value is
now 7.86 and you can check that yourself
by going into the dev tools as we talked
about in a previous lessons and hovering
over these
headlines give yourself a huge pad on
the back for all the work that you've
done you know so much already and I'm
really excited about our next lesson
together see you
there labels in all forms are a hugely
important part of EX accessible
development unfortunately elements like
input Fields often lack labels and are
replaced by placeholder text let's look
at two common designs of input
Fields this first example has a
placeholder but has no label and the
second example has a label but is
missing the placeholder text according
to the
wcag the accessibility guidelines
placeholder text is not an accessible
replacement for the label element the
placeholder should only be used as a
brief example of the text to be entered
mainly because of inconsistent support
for screen readers best case scenario an
input field has both a label and an
exemplary placeholder let's have a look
at the signup page for our Skynet eats
app seeing this you might think that
this looks like a very standard signup
form and you're right unfortunately it's
common place to see forms like this out
there that lacks labels so your
challenge should you choose to accept it
is to First add an ID attribute to each
input
field secondly add labels for each input
field in the form I want you to search
yourself how to associate a label with
an input field so that when clicking the
label the input field gets focused
alternatively you could head over to our
HTML and look at our input radio buttons
because they actually have
labels finally I want want you to change
the placeholder names to be exemplary
user inputs for example Obama for a
surname field pause now and make this
sign up page accessible to
everyone okay if you manage to do this
all on your own I am super impressed
either way let's do it together we
solved this challenge in our
HTML and the first thing that I want to
do is add an ID attribute to each input
field like
this beautiful nothing has changed yet
now let's add our label elements and I
want them to be on top of their
Associated input
fields and hopefully you manag to figure
out that the way to associate it with an
input field is to use the four attribute
and then write the ID of that specific
input field as the for
name like
that there we have the label and if you
click on it make sure that it focuses
the input field that you had in mind
let's apply a label to all the input
field let's save and have a
look beautiful every single input field
now has a label and it's associated with
the correct input field now for the
final part of the challenge it makes no
sense to have the placeholder name be
the exact copy of the label so what we
want instead is to write an example of a
full name here and here an example of an
address and so on so we are going to be
Sherlock
Holmes let's try this and voila we have
an accessible signup page and if you
noticed we also have an image and the
image has an ALT text a woman seeing a
drone approaching better yet our button
says send message which is very
non-ambiguous and clear this form
featured input Fields as well as radio
buttons another common element you will
see in forms are drop- down selection
lists but do not fret because we make
them accessible the same way we do input
Fields now the city input is a selection
menu instead and we work with labels the
same way here as with input Fields the
four attribute matching the ID attribute
on the select tag finally I want to
mentioned that the text inside links and
buttons actually acts as labels
providing an accessible name in the
browser's accessibility layer if for
whatever reason we want to create a
custom button without using the button
element we would need to add a so-called
Ariel label attribute that substitutes
the regular button label I will show you
the difference in code here quickly this
button is using the native HTML element
while this button is our custom widget
making custom button widget accessible
includes not only providing an
accessible name through Arial
labels but also implementing keyboard
accessibility and JavaScript
functionality it's often simpler and
more accessible to use the standard
button element when possible as it
inherently comes with many accessibility
features built in we will stop here
because we will dedicate a whole lesson
on Ara labels later on in the course for
now awesome work as always see you in
the next
lesson before we move on from this form
here you should know that the radio
buttons could have even more
semantically correct HTML than they
currently have we should use the field
set and Legend tags to group The set and
provide a context for screen reader
users when a screen reader encounters a
field set tag it typically announces
that the user has entered a new group or
field set this helps users understand
that the following elements are related
and should be considered as part of a
group and when a screen reader
encounters a legend tag it usually reads
it out as title or description of the
group time for a quick challenge pause
here and look up how to apply the field
set and Legend tag then come back back
here and try to make the appropriate
update to our code you don't need to add
any new elements you just need to update
the tags we already have in place give
this a
try okay if you manage to do this you
might have noticed that the styling of
our form changed that's because the
field set and Legend tags come with
inherent styling let me catch up to
you
there and this styling isn't very
consistent with the rest of our form if
you want take a moment to play around
with styling the field set element and
then I'll do it
too I hope that was a fun little break
from the accessibility work we've been
doing I myself came up with
this that's much more consistent now
let's get excited cuz it's time to
return to our sky eats app see you
soon here we go we have the final
section of our futuristic food delivery
app in place it's a sign up form to get
notified when the Skynet drones start
delivering pizza to your window I myself
want to be notified when that day comes
cuz I can't wait for such Airborne
glutenous Delight you probably already
predicted what your challenge will be
I want you to make this form accessible
in the same manner as you did in the
previous lesson we want to add labels
for each input field in the
form then we want to change the
placeholder names to be as accessible
and helpful as possible and finally we
want to update the button text to be
less ambiguous currently it's just a
check mark symbol which is quite poor
communication pause here and make this
notification form
accessible okay I hope that went well
now let's do it together first we will
go to our HTML and add the labels on top
like
this we need the four attribute but what
do we need to put in the four attribute
well we need the ID of the input field
that we're going to associate it to
which we don't have yet so make an
ID call it name and then write name up
there it full
name
that should be it and we have the labels
but now the placeholders need updating
as well so let's write an example
here okay much better now we need to
make the button much less ambiguous than
this so we remove this symbol I'm going
to
write notify me because that's exactly
what I want to happen when I press the
button great finally I hope you also
went into our CSS and found this
selector for the
placeholder and updated this color
because currently it's light gray and
difficult to see so let's make it a
darker gray beautiful wasn't that easy
and pretty effortless join me in our
next lesson where we will have a recap
of semantic
HTML see you
there want to know an awesome fact
96.5% of websites have accessibility
issues that you can prevent by just
knowing the fundamental
the very same fundamentals that you're
learning here in this course next we
will have a brief recap of semantic HTML
which is the use of descriptive tags in
our HTML you might wonder why
descriptive tags are so important after
all you can use a combination of CSS and
JavaScript to make just about any HTML
element behave in what whatever way you
want but it makes sense to use the
correct element for the job the major
benefit is that certain assisted
technologies will use different HTML
tags to navigate through a website
semantic HTML doesn't take any longer to
write than non-semantic markup if you do
it consistently from the start of your
project even better semantic mark markup
has another benefit Beyond accessibility
in that search engines like Google give
more importance to keywords inside
headings links Etc than keywords
included in non-semantic
divs so your content will be more
findable by potential users we have tags
that are so-called Landmark regions and
they can be a nav a header main a
section and footer and they help
communicate the layout and important
areas of a page and can allow quick
access to these different regions
because this is a bit of a recap for you
I will challenge you to apply what you
know about semantic HDML straight on our
homepage your task is to update our code
with descriptive tags using the landmark
regions nav main section and footer
secondly your task is to update our
submit button to be a button element and
I'm talking about this submit button in
our form right
here pause here and show off your
descriptive tag
skills
welcome back I hope that semantic HTML
is starting to make sense to you let's
do the challenge together
now this is our nav currently coded as a
div tag so let's change that very
simply we write nav next we have the
main content which is always positioned
between the nav and the footer so we
changed this to
Main and this is the end
tag beautiful finally here's our
footer closing tag
excellent remember that our challenge
was to also use sections so this is a
good start but in our main content we
have several different sections here's
one place where it makes sense to use
The Landmark region
section and
here here as
well amazing nothing changed on the
surface but behind the curtains it's
much more
accessible finally we have a submit
button here but it's coded as a div tag
it should be a
button like
this fantastic that's all we need to do
for now are changes manifest in easier
navigation using assistive Technologies
like screen readers because they can
quickly identify these landmarks and
provide shortcuts or navigation commands
to jump directly to these sections for
example a user can skip directly to the
main main content or quickly access the
navigation menu this reduces time and
effort required to navigate through
unnecessary content enhancing the
efficiency of the user experience
Landmark regions also help users
understand the layout and organization
of a page so when a screen reader enters
a new section it can announce the type
of landmark like navigation or main
content this contextual information is
crucial for users who cannot visually
perceive the page layout using standard
landmarks across websites creates a
predictable browsing experience users
become familiar with common landmarks
knowing where to expect certain types of
content like a footer for contact
information I suggest looking up screen
reader demos online to get a better
sense of the user experience with and
without semantic HTML onwards and
upwards coders you are doing amazing ly
see you in the next lesson where we will
write accessible
lists this is a continuation of applying
descriptive tags to our HTML and here we
are going to focus on lists any
consecutive items in our code should be
either an ordered or unordered list with
list items not just a bunch of repeating
divs your challenge is pretty
straightforward
identify any connected consecutive items
secondly update the sections to be
unordered lists thirdly wrap each item
with a list item tag and finally add the
necessary CSS to maintain the style of
the sections there are several places on
our homepage where we have connected
consecutive items that need to be turned
into lists so so pause here and give it
a
go okay I hope that went well now you
can watch me do the same the first place
we have consecutive items is in our nav
bar with our nav links so let's go to
our
HTML and find our
Navar and this container right here
should be made into an un ordered list
now I'm just going to Sidetrack briefly
and tell you about a neat little trick
if you press contrl D on a PC or command
D on Mac after highlighting any text in
your code it will additionally highlight
the very next place in your code where
you have the same text so I highlighted
both the opening and the closing tag of
the div now I can just write the
unordered list tag another neat trick is
to hold down the ALT key on PC or the
option key on Mac and press in multiple
locations this allows you to type in
multiple locations at once like this
it's a really handy time
saer and here the closing
tags now if we save we see that we have
made the naar into an unordered list and
we see that by these markers now we
don't want these markers to be there but
they are default styling of list items
we will remove them later first we will
focus on adding all of our lists in this
section we have our next set of
connected consecutive items these stats
right
here and we find them
here
and finally our footer has connected
consecutive
items so this should also be a
list and we wrap each link in a list
item
tag
now if we save we see that the list
applied but we want to remove these
markers so we head into our CSS and up
at the top where we Define our general
selectors I will add a new one this is
for all unordered lists and there is a
property called list style type and if
we add
none the markers disappear of course it
would have been possible to Simply use a
series of div elements but remember how
we in the previous lesson talked about
semantic HTML and how it involves using
HTML elements for their given purpose
this practice is key in making content
accessible for all users including those
using assisted Technologies when
encountering a list screen readers
announce the start and end of lists as
well as information about the number of
items helping users grasp the content
structure however when using div tags
for listing items we lose this semantic
Clarity and that's why we should love
using list tags instead amazing work as
always and I'm really excited to talk
about font size in the next
lesson I don't know about you but I
actually have pretty bad eyesight
nothing that lenses or glasses can't fix
which makes me very fortunate but at my
normal viewing distance when sitting in
front of my
computer this is how our homepage looks
to me without lenses or glasses but this
is how our website would look for some
people even with visual aids okay let's
go back to normal for people that prefer
it they can change the default text size
setting in their browser to make all
text bigger and easier to read without
needing to use the browser Zoom tool the
problem is that the pixel unit we
commonly use is a fixed unit of
measurement and it does not scale with
changes in the browser's default font
size to reiterate using the pixel unit
is compatible with zooming in and out
but in order to accommodate user
settings we can instead use a unit in
CSS called
REM spelled out like this as you may
know by now the default font size is 16
pixels that's the font size of our
paragraphs even before we added a font
size property one Rim is equal to our
default font size in this case 16 pixels
the reason we want to write for example
one Rim instead of 16 pixels is so that
users can change the default size to be
say 32 pixels instead of 16 pixels when
they do that our text with one R all of
a sudden becomes 32 pixels large
alleviating our users from manually
having to use the zoom tool in the
Brower
and with that I have a task for you
simply change all font size properties
from Pixel to REM units right here in
the CSS and you'll need to do some
simple calculations here if you need a
calculator divide the pixel size with 16
and you'll get how many Rim it should be
see you in a
bit okay I hope that it didn't cause too
much headache to do the calculations
working with units is definitely
something that comes natural over time
let's do it together from the top
down okay I think we have our first font
size here to change this is 16 pixels so
that translates to one
R then we have 80 pixels that should
translate to five
R here's 1.20 five
R three
Ram
1.25
2.5 three
RAM and finally one r
and if we go back to our website and
have a
look the font sizes remain unchanged if
you want you could change the default
text size in your browser and see how it
affects our text amazing work as always
I'll see you in the next
lesson when I was starting to code
something stuck with me and something
sadly didn't headings was one of these
things I skipped headings I used
paragraph tags instead of heading tags
you name it this graph shows how screen
reader users mainly navigate websites
and headings is by far the most common
way therefore it's super important that
we apply them properly fortunately it's
really simple we just need to be mindful
of three main rules heading numbers
should be consecutive 1 2 3 4 and so on
we should only use one H1 per page and
finally we should apply them for
structure not style the style we can
change however we like in our CSS our
homepage is currently not following
these
rules your challenge is to apply
headings correctly throughout our HTML
make sure of the following first there's
one H1 heading no more no less secondly
heading levels are not skipped they are
consecutive and finally headings always
introduce new content sections pause
here and update the
homepage okay I hope you managed now I
will do what you just
did luckily as you probably noticed list
there is really only one section that we
need to make changes to and it's the
info section right
here remember how we should only have
one H1 heading per page well in this
section we already have one for our
Skynet eats text so this should not be
another H1 change that to
H2 and then in our list down here we
have H4 tags and H2 straight into H4 is
not a consecutive pattern so we want to
change all of these
h3s we apply headings for structure and
never style that's it and because we
style our headings in our CSS nothing
has changed by changing the heading tags
in our
HTML really fantastic work you are the
superhero of the hour and that's all you
need to know on descriptive tags we're
really getting close to the end now next
we will have a look at something called
Arya so see you
there in earlier lessons I briefly
mentioned something called Arya Arya
stands for accessible Rich internet
applications Arya is a set of attributes
that you can add to HTML elements to
provide more context and information to
assist Technologies it helps fill in the
gaps where html's Native semantics fall
short let me show you an example these
two buttons look identical right well I
made one of them using the semantic HTML
button
element and the other is just a regular
div element that I style to look exactly
the same but here is where they
currently
differ the but Buton element is
inherently keyboard accessible and
focusable when users navigate the web
page using a keyboard they can reach an
activate the button using the Tab Key
and Enter space key respectively screen
readers inherently recognize button
elements as interactive controls along
with the button label and the button
element does not require additional ARA
attributes to be recognized as a button
since it has built-in semantics when we
use the button element we get all this
accessible functionality for free but
when we decide to make a custom button
like
this we lose out on that functionality
so we need to use ARA to reintroduce
some of its functionality you can
already tell that in most cases it is
way easier for us to just use the
semantic HTML tags this is known as the
first rule of ARA is don't use ARA well
that's a bit contradictory isn't it what
it means is that if you can use a native
HTML element or attribute with the
semantics and behavior you require
already built in instead of repurposing
an element and adding an ARA Ro state or
property to make it accessible then do
so to make this div accessible it would
need additional attributes such
as roll button to Define its Ro as a
button and tab index zero to make it
keyboard focusable even with these
attributes it might still lack some of
the built-in accessibility features of a
native button in this case an Arial
label attribute would probably be
redundant because the sign up label is
explanatory enough but what's a typical
use case then for ARA well they include
elements like toggle switches sliders
and non-standard labels I just added a
common type of toggle switch to our
website a dark theme
toggle these elements sometimes lack
native semantics making it challenging
for assisted Technologies to interpret
them correctly which is true for our
toggle right now so here's a challenge
for you I want you to add the three ARA
attributes that do the following first
define the role of the toggle switch
then make the toggle switch keyboard
focusable and lastly communicate the
state to assisted Technologies in some
way in our case that the toggle is on or
off you might need to look up what value
to use for the role attribute here and
that gives us a chance to practice
searching for information which is a big
part of any developer's job pause here
and give this a
go did you figure it out no worries if
you didn't that's why we're doing this
together
here the role attribute defines the role
of an element to assist of Technologies
in the context of this custom toggle
switch roll switch indicates that the
element is intended to be used as a
switch similar to a checkbox but
typically used for onoff States if we
omit the role attribute here assisted
Technologies may not recognize it as an
interactive element the ARA checked
attribute here tells the screen reader
whether the switch dis activated or not
without area checked there's no
accessible way for assestive
Technologies to determine the state of
the custom switch and tab index
introduces keyboard
accessibility to summarize we want to
use ARA when we're creating a UI
component that doesn't exist in HTML we
need to provide additional information
or context to assistive Technologies
which can't be achieved with HTML alone
however avoid using ARA if the same
functionality can be achieved with
Native HTML elements as we wrap up
remember that ARA is a powerful tool for
enhancing accessibility but it should be
used judiciously and thoughtfully its
role is to complement HTML and not
replace it great job and see you in the
next
lesson ARA live regions are part of a
web page marked to be dynamically
updated when content changes in these
regions it is announced by screen
readers without the need for the user to
navigate to the changed content common
use cases for ARA live regions include
realtime notifications like
these or such as status messages after
form submissions and updates resulting
from on page filtering or
searches we use an attribute called ARA
controls to connect the cause element
with the effect element and we can also
choose between different settings for
how these changes are announced for this
we use an attribute called ARA live when
it has the value off that is the assumed
default for elements so it should not be
necessary to set this explicitly ARA
live polite is by far the most common
one to use any region which receives
updates that are important for the user
to receive but not so rapid as to be
annoying should receive this attribute
the screen reader will announce this
change when there is a natural pause in
their speech are alive with the value of
assertive should only be used for time
sensitive or critical notifications that
absolutely required the user's immediate
attention generally a change to an
assertive live region will interrupt any
announcement a screen reader is
currently making as such it can be both
annoying and disruptive and should only
be used sparingly let's look at an
example once the submit button here is
clicked we have a JavaScript function
that replaces it with this
paragraph originating from right
here thanks to using the ARA controls
attribute here we point assistive
Technologies towards an ARA live region
the element with the ID of submit
message match in the ID here a screen
reader for example would thereby detect
the change in the content of the ARA
live region and read its content but we
want to do so politely as in we want the
screen reader to announce the new
content when it has time in between
reading other content so I have a
challenge for you update the code so
that pressing the submit button politely
announces the new revealed submit
message pause here and do this
now okay so we should use the attribute
Ariel live we should put it in this
element that we create when we press the
submit button let's do it right here and
it should have the value
polite great job now there's one more
thing we could do to make life easier
especially for users with assistive
Technologies there's a concept called
programmatic Focus management this
technique involves controlling the
browser's focus in response to certain
user actions like opening a menu or
dialogue programmatic Focus management
should be used when opening models or
menus to direct the user's attention
after completing actions like form
submissions to bring Focus to relevant
content or controls or to maintain a
logical flow of navigation especially
for keyboard users notice how number two
here describes exactly what we are doing
in our web page because of that I want
you to try to do this for our web page
all on your own so I want you to add
Focus to the home link when the user
submits a message by selecting the
correct element and adding the focus
function call to it you will add a line
of code up here in the function and you
will need to add something to the HTML
as well and I want you to try to figure
out what that is but it involves somehow
getting the home link element in the
same way as we get the submit button
pause here and give this a
go did you figure it out regardless I
will do it with you
now I will start by adding an ID to the
link tag here let's call it home
link then I will get access to the home
link in the same way I get access to the
submit button up here let me actually
just copy this
and then we want to call the focus
function on the home link like
so now if you try it out it works
beautifully when we press the submit
button not only do we get this message
informing us that the form was submitted
successfully but screen readers are
informed of this too without having to
navigate to this new informational
element first focus is also placed on a
link to the homepage which makes sense
since we are probably done here on the
form page and this helps users with
assist of Technologies a lot it's
important to note that we should only
use live regions for essential updates
and avoid overuse of focus management as
it can easily disorient users if not
done logically so in summary ARA live
regions and programmatic focus
management are Advanced Tools in your
accessibility tool kit used effectively
they can greatly enhance the user
experience for screen readers and
keyboard users alike keep these
techniques in mind as you develop more
interactive and accessible web
applications and I will see you in the
next
lesson functions are red for Loops are
blue scrim by is great and so are you I
wanted to end on something fun and this
is something that you can impress anyone
with and hopefully helps you think more
creatively about accessibility
we will make a hidden link for skipping
straight to the main content of our
homepage have you ever looked up a
recipe on a recipe site and because of
the long introduction there's a link
saying something like go to recipe and
when you click on it you get to skip all
the stuff you weren't interested in
that's exactly what a skip navigation
link does for users that navigate by
tabbing through focusable items on a
site it can be frustrating to tab
through all the navigation links before
arriving to the main content therefore
we will offer a link that skips straight
to the main
content this is a website for coding
poetry and it has a long list of
navigation links try pressing your tab
key now and notice what happens you may
need to refresh your little browser
window I'll
wait did you see that our skip
navigation link suddenly appeared from
the side and if we click the link it
takes us down to the main content and
disappears
again I think this is super cool by now
you are well aware how links work but
how are we making it appear and
disappear there are several ways to hide
an element and in this case some of them
are not accessible and some of them are
the reason these
approaches are not accessible is because
we can't focus the elements but with one
of these on our right we can I have a
couple tasks for you the first one is to
make this into an accessible link and
you'll need to apply the knowledge
you've learned about links from our
previous lessons there are more than one
way to make it into an accessible link
so use your creativity pause now and
give this a
go I hope that went well now let's do it
together it would be enough to Simply
make the link blue and uh say apply an
underline but I will do something
slightly different I will add a
border and some padding
and Border
radius now if we take a look we see that
something is sticking out here and I
styled it with the intent to shift it a
bit more to the
left just like this and then we also
need to change it here and now if we
have a look I think that looks pretty
good excellent work feel free to play
around with it some more when you're
ready to move on we will look at one
potential issue with our link see you in
the next
lesson while our skip navigation link
looks great there is still a problem if
we decide to hide it like this it's not
great if it just jumps in and out of you
like this since a user may not expect it
they might quickly tap past it not
knowing it was ever there one solution
to this is to apply a transition period
this is your challenge look up the
transition CSS property and make it so
that our skip navigation link takes 1
second to appear when focused and 3
seconds to disappear when no longer
focused pause now and try to figure out
how to do
this if you managed to do this I am
beyond impressed if not don't worry I'll
show you so that you can do it with ease
in the future all we have to do is add
the transition property to our skip
navigation link and add one second like
that with second being represented by an
s
this means that it will take 1 second to
transition from this state to the state
we Define in our pseudo class and
because we want the transition to be
slightly different when we no longer
focus on the element we add it here as
well with 3 seconds instead of one pause
quickly here and see what this did now
you see that even if we tap quickly past
our skip navigation link it won't
immediately disappear and users will
therefore know that it is there this is
not the most important accessibility
feature to have on a website but it can
definitely be fun awesome work when you
feel ready I will see you back at our
homepage welcome back I will send you
off on a quest straight away your
challenge is to build your very own skip
navigation link for our homepage there
are two requirements its default State
should be visually hidden yet accessible
to all keyboard users and secondly it
should utilize the transition property
pause now and follow these five steps
good luck and I'll be waiting for you on
the other
side you are incredible and I hope this
got your creative juices flowing the
first step was to add the skip
navigation Link in our
HTML and we put it here right above the
logo then we want to add an hre
attribute and we want to point it to our
main content which is here to connect
them this needs the
ID same name as we put up
here great but right now it's displacing
our whole navbar so let's apply some
CSS I simply added the same CSS as we
did in the previous lesson in fact you
have now learned the essentials of
accessible development and we have
finally ared at your last big challenge
when you feel ready I will see you
there in this final challenge we are
presented with a brand new contact page
of our drone food delivery site that on
the surface might look good for many
however there are several accessibility
violations hiding in the code of this
page and it's up to you to identify them
write them out as a comment right here
to make sure that you have identified
everything there is when you can't find
any more accessibility violations we
will go through this together pause here
and happy
searching I am sure you found a lot of
them let's have a
look you may have noticed that the
placeholder text is kind of difficult to
read with this light gray color on a
white
background so we should add that
here furthermore we see we have an image
here and when we have an image it needs
to have an ALT tag if we go into our
HTML we find our image down there and it
does not have an ALT tag currently
so we add this to our
list that's hugely
important now we have a look again and
not only are the placeholder names
difficult to read but this form has
several accessibility issues another
being the complete lack of
labels and what about this button a
button that just says done is a little
bit ambiguous
so that's also something we would prefer
changing I think that's it from what we
can see by just looking at a page but we
need to head into our HTML to see how
the code is
structured we have the body tag here but
while this div has an IDE of main it
lacks the main tag on top of that the
page starts with an H2 instead of an H1
heading finally if we head to our CSS
file we notice that font sizes are
defined in pixels and not R so we will
first
add that semantic HTML is lacking and
finally
that the font sizes are defined in
pixels rather than R okay that should be
all of them let's start
fixing this is the moment we've been
waiting for apply your amazing coding
skills and knowledge of accessible
development to make this page delightful
for everyone to use by fixing each and
every one of these accessibility issues
issues pause now and I will see you very
soon okay I hope most of that was now
effortless for you let's fix these
issues one by one in order first we need
to update the placeholder text color so
that the contrast has a AAA level
accessibility here's the color for the
placeholder text and I checked in
advance and this color on a white
background will give us a great contrast
value and as we see it's so much easier
to read next up the alternative text for
our image is missing so let's go into
our HTML and we have our image down here
and we'll just add the alt
tag that description makes sense to me
beautiful next next we do not currently
have labels for our input Fields so
let's add
those and this is connected to the ID of
our input field which it doesn't
currently have so we need to add the ID
and name it whatever we put
here let's write full
name
that works let's add the labels for the
other input
fields and this text area should have a
label
to
now here's a part that I intentionally
left out do you notice how the
placeholder name and the label are
currently the same when you thought
about what to name your labels your
ideal solution would have been to name
the labels like this and then change the
placeholder names to be a appropriate
examples for
instance
and if we do that we don't have any
repeating text moving on the button text
was definitely a little bit ambiguous so
instead of just saying done let's
describe the
action like this that's
better now we need to look at our
semantic
HTML and make sure that we are using
descriptive tags the first issue we saw
was that this was just a div when it
should be a main
tag secondly the main heading of our new
page should be an H1 not H2 we should
not skip heading
numbers and finally font sizes should
not be defined in pixels but rather we
should Define them in REM here we have
the first one and this is
PR this is 1.25
REM and this is one
Rim that's it you're done you made both
the homepage and the contact page of
Skynet eats website accessible to all
users phenomenal
work you did it you were able to step by
step take a website and make it much
more accessible let's do a brief recap
of what we have learned so far we
learned the importance of text contrast
and the different accessibility grades
AAA being the best we learned to always
include an ALT tag for images in our
HTML and how to write descriptive
alternative texts we learned how to code
accessible links form fields we got a
recap on semantic HTML and even got to
code a link that skips straight to the
main content of a page being able to
develop accessibly is such a superpower
and something that will make you and
your future project stand out from the
rest I'll leave you with a little rhyme
accessibility is important that much is
true the scrimba community is great and
you're part of it too best of luck in
your next endeavor